it's got a melting point of about 28
degrees so in Spain it's a liquid but in
this country it's a solid many years ago
the professor bet me a hundred pounds
when 100 pounds was a lot of money that
the melting point of gallium was lower
than that of caesium and I said it was
the other way around but I wasn't
current courageous enough to take up the
BET ORN and be rich
these look like bullets they're quite
incredible it's just the way they've
been cast I think you can buy metals as
powders or as wires or you know any
other form which the manufacturer give
you but for some reason they've just
molded them in these pallets shape lumps
and if I warm that up then it would just
melt and it would just be a liquid metal
a bit like mercury is gallium compounds
are not very important compared to many
of the others in the periodic table but
it's an area which still has quite a lot
of exploration to be done and I think
there may be some interesting surprises
so this is a small sample of gallium
okay now gallium is a really quite nice
metal because it melts at a really low
temperature so if we stand here and heat
it we can make this another liquid metal
to join mercury really quite fantastic
sample really lovely